como una luz de Esperanza así
describieron el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del eln la finalización del
primer ciclo de negociaciones en su
intento por lograr un acuerdo de paz
definitivo entre las dos partes luego de
21 días de reuniones a Puerta cerrada
acordaron cuatro puntos incluyendo el
reconocimiento de la grave situación de
violencia en los territorios y atención
de emergencia en departamentos como el
Valle del cauca y chocó las partes
reconocen la grave situación de
violencia que se presenta en los
territorios Y decidieron poner en
ejecución un acuerdo parcial de atención
de emergencias que iniciará a partir de
enero del 2023 las conversaciones de
Park reiniciaron el pasado 21 de
noviembre en Caracas con la intención de
finalizar un conflicto de casi seis
décadas el primer acercamiento se
realizó en el 2017 durante el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos pero fue
suspendido en el 2019 durante el mandato
de Iván Duque luego de que el perpetuará
un ataque que dejó a 22 policías muertos
el apoyo internacional ha jugado un
papel crucial en estas nuevas
negociaciones recientemente los
gobiernos de México y chile se sumaron a
Cuba Noruega y Venezuela como garantes
mientras que Alemania Suecia Suiza y
España son acompañantes el respaldo que
recibe esta mesa por parte de la
comunidad internacional es muy
importante Nosotros le hemos dicho que
lo agradecemos Y como dice su palabra
nos acompañan y nos reemplazan los
esfuerzos de los colombianos para que
esta tarea de la paz recaiga ese hombros
de las dos delegaciones por su parte el
gobierno mexicano confirmó que la
próxima Ronda de negociaciones se
realizará en su país a partir de enero
en las cuales se espera lograr un cese
al fuego bila